sur cette île dupas cannois
vous allez devoir survivre pendant 38
jours sans rien vous êtes sûr que c'est
là là parce qu'il n'y a pas de vie la
firme algériens doivent construire nous
mêmes tout construire avec trois ânes
nos mains peut-être
vont dépasser la fin on classe lada il
n'y a pas de déjouer ni de dîner roy la
fatigue a bien dormi du tout bien oui
les trahisons évidemment que je voulais
travailler on va te contre lui
mais non moins grosses merdes volent
instants de la vie
oh [ __ ] c'est aux sauvegardes seul de
ses 14 aventuriers succèdera à lionel
qui a remporté les 450 euros une somme
folle rien ne l'empêchera de gagner les
450 euros la guerre elle fait que
commencer je suis ravi de faire partie
de cette aventure humaine tais toi
maintenant aucun secret pour moi c'est
la bonne humeur sur alarme qui me fera
gagner
ce que tu es
[Musique]
les rôles ont fait vomir ses seuls
moyens de perdre du poids rapidement
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle le multiverse